Hi, I'm Robert Downey Jr.!
Check out the exclusive new trailer for my upcoming film, "Sherlock Holmes: A Game of Shadows",...
...only on iTunes trailers.
Please sit. Put your money on the table.
Welcome.
The cards can illuminate your future.
I have a feeling you're in danger.
Actually, I prefer to read your fortune.
I see that your next client is here to kill you.
Oh, how I've missed you, Holmes.
I see that your web of conspiracy has expanded.
I'm knee-deep in the single, most important case of my career.
The clues point in one direction,...
...Professor James Moriarty.
Are you sure you want to play this game?
I'm afraid you'd lose.
I'll agree it's not my best disguise, but I have to make do.
Didn't see this on the cards, did you?
What are we doing down here?
We are waiting.
Make it count.
I'm on my honeymoon!
Get that out of my face.
It's not in your face. It's in my hand.
Get what's in your hand out of my face.